Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
We mentioned that these first verses of
are a preparation for the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
in order for him to call to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. The more any person
has these traits,
the more
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
they are in their calling to Allah.
Calling to Allah
is the greatest opportunity and the
highest order of affairs that any human
being can be used by Allah for.
And that is that a person helps to free
people from the slavery of this world
and the slavery of hellfire and bring
them into the light of the of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Now what are the
traits that a person needs to have in
order to be effective and to be
qualified
in calling to Allah and what are the
points that a person should focus on in
their calling to Allah. Often times we
find that some personalities
are very well known for inviting people
to Islam or calling people to Islam but
often times they get distracted by
details that are peripheral in their
invitation to Islam.
So they will go into deep nuance
discussions with people of other
religions regarding the minutia and
details of the Bible and the New
Testament and the Old Testament and the
Quran and this issue and that issue and
the you know the the Gospel of
Barnabas and all of these things. This
is not necessary for a person who calls
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. When a
person calls to Allah, they focus on the
most important issues.
And so what are those issues? Well, the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam told us and
he understood that from these verses and
verses it. When we look at Noisam,
Ibraim MSa,
we look at the stories of Hud and
L and all of these great
highly esteemed messengers of Allah.
Allah tells us when they come to their
people, what do they all say in one word
or another?
worship Allah and worship none other
than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. That is
the beginning and end and what the
entire religion of Islam and the
relationship between a servant and his
creator revolves around and is founded
upon. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
He says in the chapter of
he says, "And we have never sent a
messenger before you, oh Muhammad,
except that we send revelation to him
that none is rightfully worshiped, but I
so worship me." This is what a person
focuses on when they call to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. They focus on the
worship of Allah alone
and the worship of Allah in the way that
[Arabic recitation]
They focus on
and Bkari Muslim
Abbas and others they narrate that when
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
sent Muad to Yemen.
He said to him and this was when he was
instructing him sending him there to
invite the people to Islam to call the
people of Yemen to Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala.
He said,
[Silence]
"The prophet Prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam said to him
you are going to arrive upon a people
who are a people of the book.
So let the first thing that you call
them to and invite them to be the
worship of Allah.
that they the oneness that they worship
Allah alone without any partners. And in
another wording, he said, "Let the first
thing that you invite them to be that
none is rightfully worshiped but Allah
and that I am the messenger of Allah."
This is what a person calls people to
Islam with. And this is what all of the
teachings are based on. A person does
not go off into peripheral issues. four
wives and a person should have three
wives or two wives or if a person cuts
the hand off of a thief or the nuances
of the story of Jalut and Talut or what
really happened between and
the what was MS's stick made out of and
what was the type of tree that Adam and
Hwah ate from and all of these things
that are nothing but details that
detract
from
the core core and essence of the da of
Islam. The da and the invitation, the
calling, the way of the prophets and
messengers and the scholars and and
imams of Islam throughout history. A
person focuses on what? Focuses on the
worship of Allah alone without any
partners. Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
makes that the first thing that he he
tells the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
to do and instructs him with. He says
stand and warn. What shall I warn? What
shall I do?
And your lord exalt exalt your lord. Be
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala be the
main thing that you discuss
that the names the attributes of Allah.
Exalt Allah and his commandments. Exalt
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Exalt Allah in that the beginning and
end of your da'wah be based upon the
exaltation of Allah.
What is it that for instance how do we
embody the exaltation of Allah? It's not
just saying Allahbar. How do we embody
it? If a person worships Allah and
worships another along with Allah, have
they exalted Allah? No. They have made
something of his creation equal to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So you exalt Allah
by worshiping only Allah. You exalt
Allah by not affirming superstitions,
by rejecting superstition
and trickery and astrology and all of
these things even to the point that we
do not swear by other than Allah. We
only fear Allah. We only love Allah in
the way that we love Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and an unconditional worship
right we hope in Allah we fear Allah
only Allah none other if we fear someone
or something else
we fear Allah we have not exalted
Allah we have not fulfilled the
statement of Allah
He says,
"Purify your clothing, purify your
actions, fulfill your your
testaments, and fulfill your alliances
and allegiances. All of these meanings
purify your actions." He then says
the third point and abandon.
Now what is arroges?
The scholars
mention arroges.
In the Quran the word is a punishment.
It's a calamity. It's a punishment from
Allah. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that he sends down a ridges
he sends down from the heavens a
punishment upon those who disobey him
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So
is that which brings on calamity
and what is the main thing that brings
on destruction from Allah? the worship
of other than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So many of the companions explain this
narrate this verse to mean and abandon
the worship of idols. Abandon idolatry
and all that is connected to idolatry.
Not just bowing to a not just bowing
to an idol but the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam prohibited
even worshiping Allah in a place where
idols are exalted in the way that the
worship of idols take place. A man came
to the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
and said I have vowed to slaughter a
sacrifice in Buena. Buena is a place out
in the outskirts of Mecca.
Why? Why Buena? Why is your oath that I
swear I vow to slaughter a sacrifice
specifically in Buana?
Why buana? Why not anywhere in the
world? So the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam asked him he said
is there an idol that used to be
worshiped there in Buana? He said no. He
said, "Was there ever a holiday of the
mushri or a celebration that they would
make there in Bana?" He said, "No." He
said,
he said, "Then fulfill your vow." So a
person is not allowed to not even just
not worship idols or worship other than
Allah but do not do anything that would
confuse you with the worship of other
than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that if
someone saw you they would confuse you
with an idoltor
and so this is all part of
the next statement is so important it
cannot be emphasized ized enough. He
says, "Subhan,
[Silence]
he says, "And do not reproach in that
action and your allegiance to Allah,
your calling to Allah, your good deeds.
Do not reproach them and feel that you
are doing a service to Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala. This cannot be emphasized
enough. What is that? The statement of
Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says, "And
whoever strives in Allah's obedience,
they are striving for the good of their
own soul."
Indeed, Allah does not need any of his
creation.
And so he's telling the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam,
you are going to carry this message. You
are going to deliver it as it is
descended upon you. But do not reproach
either your Lord or the recipients of
that message. Do not reproach. What is
reproach? Elman. What is alman? That a
person feels they're doing others a
favor. they are owed because of
their service. That he is the messenger
of Allah. He is receiving this huge
responsibility.
Now those who follow him, you all owe
me. I'm higher than you. I am better
than you because look what I'm doing for
you. Right? Or that a person has this
towards their Lord. What is that? That
they feel that they are excellent. That
Allah cannot do without them. That they
are integral to Allah's message. That
without them, what would the world do
without me? Oh, it would fall apart
without me. Right? This kind of emotion,
this kind of feeling, this is called
alman. And if it is towards another
person, it will invalidate any charity a
person gives. And if it is towards
Allah, it is referred to as
aljub means that a person takes himself
very seriously and thinks that you
know he is he he is profound. Look how
great I am. Look what I've done. Look
how great I am. Look how many people
I've called to Islam and how many
massagid I've built and I and then all
these stories about how I rolled up my
sleeves and I served and I did and I
that as if somebody owes you something
for this. You do this, it is for your
own good. It is not for the good of
anyone else. Yes, others may be
benefited of it, but ultimately this is
something for yourself. If you did not
do it, you would be the loser, not
others. Not others. Others would not be
the loser because the religion of Allah
continues no matter who is present for
it. The messenger of Allah
saiam
died and the message continued. Imagine.
So then who does Allah need? He needs no
one. We need him. And anytime we do
something good, I'm doing this for my
own self. It doesn't mean that we don't
thank people for their service. Doesn't
mean that we don't owe those who serve
us respect those who teach us, those who
call us. We do. But this is to the
person. This this statement of Allah is
not speaking about the people, the
recipients of the message. It's speaking
about the person who delivers the
message. Do not go through life feeling
you are owed by people. Otherwise,
you will burn yourself out. People will
never repay you. They'll never repay
you. How could a per how can you repay a
prophet? How how could you how could we
repay the prophet Muhammad? How could we
repay Al Bkari? Tell me. Tell me how we
could repay him. Is there any amount of
money in the whole world that we could
give him to repay him for his service?
How could we repay any scholar, any
messenger, any scholar, any prophet? How
could we repay a martyr? Tell me, what
amount of money could we pay? Someone
who teaches us and opens the doors of
Allah's mercy upon us. How could we
repay them?
Tell me the amount of money it would
take to repay someone who teaches you
one verse of the Quran. Tell me what is
one verse worth? It's impossible to
repay them. Impossible to repay them.
This is why the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam commanded us to constantly make
dua for those who have come before us.
Those who are with us, who teach us,
they will never be able to be repaid.
only by Allah only Allah could repay
them. However, the person delivering
that message don't expect payment
because if you expect payment and
reciprocity for your efforts, you won't
ever receive it. People will never
fulfill your rights or thank you enough.
But if you are going through life
feeling I do this, I am owed. I'm
better. Right? I let's say I build a
masid and then people come and I feel
yeah thank me now who could now
thank me for building you all this masid
you could never thank me enough this
behavior will invalidate a person's
deeds it will invalidate a person's
deeds
oh you have believed do not invalidate
your charities and your deeds by
reproach.
If I give someone and then I say, "I
gave you, thank me." And then I wait
till we're in a gather, I say, "Hey man,
you remember when I gave you this and
that? Huh? I did you a great service,
man." So on and so it's better if you
don't give him. Leave him poor and let
him keep his dignity. That is better.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
He says, "Saying something good
and refraining from harming someone is
better than giving them charity and then
reproaching them and harming them
afterwards. It's better to leave someone
poor with their dignity intact than to
relieve something financial upon them
and then drag their dignity through the
mud and step on their neck figuratively.
And so Allah tells him
and then the final point he says
and for your Lord be patient.
And we will expound upon this and its
connection to the following verses
inshallah tomorrow night.
for
[Silence]
subhanahu
aldulill.
play on.